- and this is where we stand this
morning in the corona virus pandemic
there are now more than ninety four
hundred reported cases here in the
United States across all 50 states now
the number of deaths in this country has
jumped to at least 150 - president Trump
now says he considers himself a wartime
president because of the corona virus
last night he signed a 100 billion
dollar emergency aid package into law it
includes free virus testing for every
American paid sick leave and expanded
unemployment benefits wheeshes yang is
at the White House visa
President Trump is also expected to
reveal a significant development from
the FDA this morning what do we know
about that
oh good morning Anthony the White House
is being very tight-lipped with any
details but the president could talk
about a potential treatment for the
corona virus he has also mentioned that
researchers are working on a test that
people could give themselves in the
meantime he has taken a series of
stunning steps that underscore just how
serious this outbreak is even activating
FEMA - level 1 the highest level across
the country we're winning and we will
win it's a question of when and I think
it's going quickly before meeting with a
group of nurses on the front lines
President Trump said he was using the
full power of the federal government to
combat the corona virus we'll be
invoking the defense production act the
President signed a Korean War era law
that compels manufacturing companies to
produce certain Goods during a crisis
like masks and other protective gear for
health workers though he later said it
was for a worst-case scenario one major
concern is having enough ventilators to
help patients breathe we have a specific
number of ventilators into stock pilots
in excess of of 10,000 and you just
heard the announced
from the Department of Defense they'll
be adding several more thousand to them
on Capitol Hill lawmakers are working on
a trillion dollar economic stimulus
package to bail out the airline and
hotel industries help small businesses
and even send money directly to
Americans in need we are moving rapidly
because the situation demands it but
Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer
warned that's only a quick fix this is
not a time for small thinking this is
not a time for small measures this is a
time to be bold to be aggressive
President Trump is also under fire for
frequently referring to coronavirus as
the Chinese virus the president says the
virus originated in China and he's
pushing back on a Chinese official who
had suggested the US military brought
the disease to Wuhan it's not racist at
all no but it all comes from China but
would it be accurate but many
asian-americans say it is racist and
that the president's actions have led to
a growing number of attacks on the
community both verbal and physical Tony
Louisa thank you very much